it's ETS late-night roundup your quick
catch up on all the most buzz worthy TV
scoop after dark
it is pretty surreal and amazing that in
a few hours I'm gonna be dad so I'm just
trying to be calm and have a peaceful
birth things were definitely peaceful on
Sundays Rob and Chyna baby special where
viewers join the couple inside the
delivery room when I see baby dream for
the first time I'm definitely happy to
see that she's healthy she's just a
little cute baby it's pretty wild
Rob and Chyna had their closest friends
and family at the hospital for the
special occasion everyone was on cloud
nine over the newest Kardashian's
arrival definitely very nice to see
everybody just meant a lot to me
meanwhile there were more good vibes
over on Mariah's world thanks to the
singers rumoured beau Bryan Tanaka
I love Mariah she is extremely
thoughtful she's extremely caring
there's something so unique about her
the dancer channeled his affection into
planning a special birthday surprise for
Mariah which we'll see next week on the
show
[Music]
but could be couples possible romance
was also a hot topic on Sundays watch
what happens lies there was speculation
that your backup dancer Brian who I met
backstage was a contributing factor to
your breakup with James Packer how much
was he a factor and are you dating I
don't want to go into it but it's when
something is real and it's a beautiful
thing you don't want to just like trash
it up and okay
it is what it is Araya played coy about
having an alleged breakup agreement with
her now ex-fiance James Packer is there
a breakup agreement between me and you
never I'll always be on this show and
also had this to say about her massive
engagement range do you plan on giving
it back
why on the flip side things seem great
between Mariah and her ex-husband Nick
Cannon they reunited on stage over the
weekend in New York City with their
twins Moroccan in Monroe we tried a
co-parent Yano with the utmost respect
for each other I never want the kids to
think I tried to put a boundary between
the units it's all about family and
you